[Inaudible].
Keep it going for the hilarious Andrew shows.
Shady. How to fall.
[Inaudible].
That's not really the accident anymore. Isn't it? It's more
[inaudible].
Yeah.
It's the best city. That's why everyone comes here. I mean,
let's be honest of the cities that are a little jealous, you know,
especially Boston. You ever noticed Boston hates New York. You know what?
The funny thing is, we're not thinking about them.
At all.
[inaudible].
Boston treats, New York, like we used to date way back in the day.
Now we moved on with our lives.
It became somebody that just FAQ and stalking our Facebook page.
You're Kwok SACA It's like Boston. Let it go,
dude. We are way out of your league. All right, go date Philadelphia.
You got it.
You can tell Boston's a city.
Do you ever notice every movie about Boston is about some guy trying to get out
of bed.
[Inaudible].
It's like, well, if I see you here in the morning, I will kill you myself.
You go make something of yourself, kid.
You're not going to just hang around here. Wearing construction boots in a car.
Ben Affleck's sitting by a river bank. Finally found serenity with a hipster,
beard Credit.
They love their teams. They got a lot of pride. They just take a little too far.
You know, I shot my half-hour special there. And I came,
I was wearing a Yankee hat.
They treated me like I was wearing an ISIS t-shirt or something. And I was like,
slow it down. It's just the baseball team. I like, you know, it's like,
I'm a Yankee fan. I get it. I'm a hardcore Yankee fan.
But like I don't wear Yankees pajamas to bed every night.
No.
Yankees don't win. I'll be all right. This stuff to do here.
Not like Boston red Sox lose the crime rate,
shoots up 15% people start hitting their family members.
The cops show up like what's going on here? It's like,
well off the set of red Sox laws, Keep hitting them.
I understand sore.
Back in socks.
Really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys,
where things get really wild.